one day on set we'd kiss probably 30
times a day
it's crazy before we filmed our first
kissing scene I was incredibly nervous
relax Romeo I mean seriously you guys
seriously take me back to your first
kiss with Kenan my first kiss with Kenan
was it in the chemistry read no no we
wait was it I feel like it was a long
time ago
hey Harvey right yeah I'm Nick scratch
Sabrina sent me a friend of hers in your
backup for the night what kind of friend
before we filmed our first kissing scene
I was incredibly nervous I wrote in that
day and was talking to Brad who's one of
our transport guys he's awesome and I
was like man big day today like we're
filming this and this I'm like and I got
a kissing scene with Keira and he was
like oh really
it's like have you guys kissed before I
was like no and he was like you should
probably figure that out you're not
careful it can mess with your head I'm
trying to think about it I'm sure it was
on set I'm sure it was for a scene but
it wasn't for the porch scene it might
have been the port suit really got you
what if we kiss and it's awkward or
something and like we both go to the
same side and bump paths so I knocked
her in a trailer door before that day
started she was like hi how are you I
missed you how was your weekend I was
like just hang on and I just planted a
smooch on her and was like I'm sorry I
just had to get that out of the way my
heart is pounding I'm shaking and I just
didn't want that to be awkward on screen
for the first time that's how shush what
did she say she was so receptive it was
just like no it's all good yeah I got it
cool date thanks and how was it it was
great I like went in for one and it was
just like a quick Peck and I felt like
that was the awkward one and I was like
just one more time and then I just wish
I was like okay so I know I know what
that is like now we can move forward
from there maybe it's not so bad
hmmm no there's been a lot of life
that's happened since that so many
smooches it's really me and Kiernan and
the first season one day on set we'd
kiss probably 30 times a day it's crazy
and that's just how film works because
you know take after take after your just
smooch it of course what a job right I
know right do you think you can handle
it
[Music]